is the Bibby Stockholm barge which has
been in the headlines over the last
month or so ever since the government
and the home office announced that it
had hired it in order to house as you
say around 500 migrants later this
summer well it has in the early hours of
this morning arrived here in Falmouth
this is where it's going to undergo a
bit of a refit and some inspection work
ahead of its use from the southern
summer three stories high you can see it
has 222 bedrooms and from this summer
will be home to 500 single male Asylum
Seekers this is part of the home
office's plan to tackle the migrant
crisis the number of Asylum Seekers
coming over on dinghies making that
dangerous journey across the channel and
what we've of course have seen over the
last couple of years is the
extraordinary amount of money which is
being spent on hotels and facilities in
the region of seven million pounds they
say that the cost of this barge and
running it for those Asylum Seekers will
be quote significantly lower on board
basic accommodation is what the home
office says will be provided there is a
health care provision catering security
and so forth there are reports that it
will cost around about 20 000 pounds a
day to operate it Falmouth here in
Cornwall where the refit is taking place
uh is not the final destination for Bibi
Stockholm at once that refit has been
completed it will then be towed again
taken up to Portland Port which is a
port area just off the coast of Weymouth
in Dorset that's where it's going to be
based operational we understand for
about a year and a half it of course has
come with some controversy not only from
Charities human rights groups who say
look this simply isn't the the way that
we should be dealing with Asylum Seekers
It's not Humane to shove them on this
um pretty unattractive to be blunt
looking barge and it's not the right way
to go about things the local MP in
Weymouth as well highly critical uh of
its presence they're concerned about the
impacts on the locals as well it's going
to be very close to a tourist area and
what impact that will have from July
when we understand it will be in place
during the tourist season but the barge
has arrived and as I say it will undergo
a refit and inspection work we've seen
the workers coming on and off throughout
the day and it'll begin its journey to
be in place in Weymouth from July